tous
[Musique]
sanctionner ça va terminer c'est contre
cette conférence j'avoue que j'ai un peu
peur de parler devant vous ce soir dans
cette forme là c'est un exercice auquel
je suis habitué je
j'étais un peu partagé bajaj appréhendé
à l'idée de monter sur scène et en temps
je me disais quand tu montes sur scène
ça veut dire que c'est bientôt fini
voilà il reste pas longtemps j'ai 18
minutes et puis après il ya l'invité
surprise l'invité surprise c'est
généralement quand les organisateurs
il leur manque encore un invité dixon
surprise moi je sais qui c'est vrai
c'est pas incroyable
[Musique]
je crois que je suis presque plus connu
que lui encore te c'est bon tu sais pas
si je suis connue à fribourg donc je
m'appelle maternelle russia c'est la
première fois qu'on me présente en
allemand je reviendrai là dessus je
pense que tout le monde me connaît pas
même la majorité je parlais avec une
dame très gentille tout à l'heure dehors
qui m'a dit en vous et nathanaël rocha
humoriste parce que je me suis présenté
à me dit j'ai jamais entendu parler de
vous
je dis si tu crois que j'avais entendu
parler du tedx fribourg
c'est donnant donnant voilà c'est la
première fois que je suis présentée en
allemand j'ai pas à ce titre ben en fait
je me suis un peu préparé au fur et à
mesure des toc parce que je crois qu'on
dit comme ça ça sonne tout de suite
moins chiant quand on dit hank
je me suis préparé donc c'est peut-être
pour ça que c'est un petit peu bout de
bois mais enfin j'ai l'habitude c'est
pas grave je me disais maintien il
présente les gens en allemand et puis
après les gens parlent dans une autre
langue
j'ai pas très bien compris je vous avoue
parce que faire les interludes en
allemand pour que des gens qui
comprennent pas le français peut suivre
c'est bien mais ça leur permet
finalement de suivre que les interludes
alors moins qu' un germanophone qui soit
venu tout pour les interludes quand je
franchis pas ce que vous foutez là à
quoi ces jeux c'est bien s'il ya des
germanophones qui une fois des gens qui
parlent pas français je parle seulement
allemands qui sont intégrés puis si on
peut larguer c'est pas grave ils seront
ce que les belles chansons dimanche de
votation fribourg est un peu hybride
un compte en suisse allemand c'est un
conte en français je sais pas comment
puis après je regarde compte y aller
les diagrammes après les votations
généralement la fribourg dans la même
couleur que les cantons suisses
allemands donc je crois qu'on sait dans
quel camp vous aussi à six voies
l'annoncé très bien c'est polyglotte ça
fait assez high tech comme ça moi
pendant la conférence de madame asa des
tâches d'or j'ai fait semblant de
comprendre comme la plupart d'entre vous
j'ai bien aimé aussi le la vidéo youtube
a regretté jean bertsch plus comment
elle s'appelle à se doivent
c'était vers le site est en anglais mais
heureusement si on comprenait pas
l'anglais il y avait des sous titres qui
étaient en anglais aussi bon voila j'ai
rien compris mais ça a l'air très bien
madame azad et acheteurs enfin j'ai
surtout compris qu'elle a noté greta tim
berg d'abord qui après nous et qu'elle
avait voyagé dans 30 pays
son bilan carbone et pour un croyant non
plus et je pense pas qu'elle soit les à
jakarta en train mais enfin voilà donc
moi j'ai accepté de venir s tedx c'est
mon premier tedx shy pense que c'est
essentiellement aussi mon dernier tlx je
vends je suis pas sûr que jean 30
exactement dans l'es15 enfin vous voyez
je connaissais pas j'ai découvert j'ai
regardé un peu sur internet unique
je me suis dit c'est des conférences ça
dure trois heures qui devrait aller un
truc pareil passe normalement on dit aux
gens si vous y allez pour aller suivre
une conférence de trois heures les gens
essayent d'éviter en plus on est lundi
je lui ai dit mais qu'est ce qu'ils
foutent le mardi cela parce que
[Musique]
c'est celle des conférences du bois ça
marche très bien en fait je crois qu'il
suffit de faire payer les gens ont pu
changer le nom et puis alors on m'avait
précisé les billets sont vendus en 17
minutes 17 minutes en lundi soir pour
trois heures de conférence ça en dit
long sur l'offre fribourgeoise en
matière de divertissement en quoi sert
[Musique]
enfin j'aime bien je découvre je vois
que pour faire un td que s'ils font une
espèce de truc on voit croisé quoi s'est
il ya du budget à tous les partis
là-dessus pas sur mon cachet à parce que
moi je vous dis je suis venu déjà un peu
par curiosité surtout pour pour l'argent
aussi
voilà je crois tu donc il ya des règles
on m'a dit qu'il ya un tapis rouge c'est
tout il ya toujours un tapis parce qu'on
m'a dit il y aura sera accueilli sur un
tapis rouge
c'était à prendre littéralement j'ai vu
en loge à part un peu d'eau minérale n'y
a pas grand chose
enfin voila j'ai suivi avec curiosité
conférence c'était c'est un peu
fourre-tout soigner le thème de l'amour
je me suis dit mais qu'est ce que tu as
à dire sur l'amour appart avis personnel
j'y viendrai sim reste le temps et après
j'ai entendu les eaux je me suis dit
qu'on a une certaine marge de manoeuvre
quand même un fait j'ai appris plein de
choses j'ai appris le mot ikea gaillot
japonais on va parler japon à parler
toutes les langues se soit une cagade
c'est quoi la raison de se lever le
matin ils ont défoncé mois à bord c'est
moi cette piste et je pense si c'est
tout ce qu'ils entendent et les japonais
tu es très bien vont à commencer par
madame d'ailleurs que son son discours
sur le vin ça m'a donné envie de boire
j'ai entraîné non je suis un bon mois
mon coup de coeur c'était à la
conférence sur les cloches
vous avez droit de rigoler en suisse est
mal qui n'est pas susceptible ans et ça
va je sais pas ce que j'allais dire que
enfin bref non mais là bien vendu parce
qu'au début je me suis dit mais c'est de
la graine pour un dîner de cons mais non
il a réussi à il a réussi à intéresser
avec les causses moi je mange m'avouer
vaincu au départ et puis du stress que
ton m'a dit c'est sûr l'amour mais moi
qui va parler des côtes des cloches je
me suis dit on parce qu'au début j'étais
là mais c'est quoi cette histoire
j'avais déjà entendu parler de mécano
fils il ya d'autre part at il pas des
goûts bizarres mais là bas mais j'ai
trouvé très bien comme il a réussi à
nous faire partager sa passion des
cloches la chance qu'il a eue d'assister
à la montée d'une cloche donc c'est une
histoire qu'on peut raconter beaucoup
plus tard pour endormir les enfants ça a
bien des chances de marcher wayne nom
puis après c'est devenu un peu plus un
peu plus technique quand même qu'il a
dit que les cloches ne sont pas juste
des objets
puis c'est là qu'on voit que cette
conférence ted est bien construite face
juste avant il y avait le dr nomme
franck qui nous parlait de l'objectif
ication dans l'amour enfin aider à mieux
comprendre ce qui voulait dire par les
cloches ne sont pas des objets chez les
hommes frank c'était très bien
je connais un peu avec d'origine
péruvienne sur pommes et peuvent puis 50
ans celui-ci visiblement son accent
n'est pas au courant je crois que c'est
les psychiatres font toujours les psys
toujours ça pour être plus crédible quoi
c'est si on a un accent un peu original
ça fait on est mieux déclare prêt il m'a
embrouillé avec ses histoires moi j'ai
deux enfants je dois dire que chasser
impliqués dans leur éducation
bon je suis en plein divorce s'agit d'un
vrai peut-être tout à l'heure si j'ai le
temps je suis en pleine procédure de
divorce après je dois moi j'ai un peu de
mal à les éduquer peut-être que j'aurai
droit une consultation gratuite dont
anvers tout à l'heure mais cette
histoire de jeu du jeu ça quand je lui
dit d'aller se brosser les dents à mon
fils cgt moi je sais pas comment je vais
me pendre moi je leur fils du cache
généralement g
vingt balles si tu vas te coucher avant
10 heures c'est ben je crois que j'aime
mes enfants quand même mais ça m'a un
petit peu embrouillée maintenant je suis
en procédure de divorce mais j'hésitais
c'est pour dire que la vie en parlant
d'amour puisque c'est quand même le
thème est un peu désastreuse mais on est
allé voir on a décidé de divorcer
ça fait quelques années qu'on est
séparée avec la mère de mes enfants puis
on allait chez un avocat et la première
question que j'ai demandé en essayant
c'est vous prenez contre c'est quoi
votre tarif horaire l'avocat mahdi 400
francs de l'heure plus tva
je me suis tourné vers la mère de mes
enfants je lui ai dit je t'aime de
nouveau mais c'était un c'est un moment
assez difficile dont l'avocat est ce
qu'on doit s'arranger sur les conditions
du divorce qui je vais au fait il est de
bon ton de faire croire qu'on a envie de
la garde des enfants
enfin faut faire semblant enfin c'est
entre il faut faire semblant comme maire
en faut enfin je vais faire perdre au
procès quand même j'ai bien aimé la
ligue de broche était torride à au début
ça commençait doucement mais steak
torride avec cette histoire de toucher
les animateurs ont dit que après sa
conférence on aurait tous envie de se
toucher
machin au moment ils ont dit ça j'étais
assis à côté d'elle et je savais pas que
c'était elle qui allait faire la
conférence donc je me disais pourquoi
pas puis après le sait le résilie avec
tout mike à côté moi j'étais moins
enthousiastes
pour être très intéressant on fait des
études sur touche globalement des années
d'études pour nous expliquer que si on
touche son conjoint pitt ont fait
l'amour avec on est plus heureux à je
suis pour aller à l'université j'ai pas
fait de longues êtes dans la vie on dit
souvent tu es soit intellectuel soit
manuel c'est pas vrai on peut être aucun
des deux tiers mon cas mais enfin voila
je vais au sud et si j'ai envie de
parler de cul est un peu un mêmes trucs
peuvent faire passer ça l'amour
finalement personne n'a vraiment parler
apparel qui a effleuré le sujet après
j'ai vu ça chalosse et est resté bien
gênes 1 franchement c'était cool mais
qui sont l'amour des chemises j'avais
pas trop quoi dire
daniel de roulet très belle lecture
franchement c'était bien écrit avec des
mots simples que je comprendrais bien
écrit
je crois que c'est hemingway cadix et
pas forcément les grandes émotions
passent pas par des mots compliqués qui
nous halluin et quelques chapitres de
son livre un extrait de son livre
ça m'a donné envie de lire l'autre
moitié est après tout voilà vous restiez
minutes vente
je me suis dit oui je vais parler un peu
de ma vie amoureuse qui comme j'ai dit
est désastreuse sept ans je viens de me
séparer là je parle pas de ma femme de
celle qui est venue à avant je me suis
dit waouh je sais pas j'ai regardé votre
tête mais je dois je peux y aller quoi
non je divorce assez je viens de me
faire quitter donc jeu
c'est pareil de mon épouse après jetée
avec une femme puis on s'est séparés
puis je me faisais la réflexion puisque
on a parlé d'amour mais j'ai jamais
vraiment une chance en amour habib bon
c'est vrai que j'ai lu dans la plaquette
de présentation pour la conférence danic
de brottes
une des questions centrales et je cite
ainsi pendant 15 ans était faut-il se
toucher le plus souvent possible
alors moi ça m'a un petit peu
décomplexée j'ai l'impression que la
réponse est oui et après j'ai compris
qu'on peut on n'est pas du même sujet
mais enfin ça me parle maintenant que je
suis célibataire depuis quelques temps
moi j'ai jamais eu de chance en amour
vous donner des exemples ça ira plus
vite une première copine j'avais une
vingtaine d'années jean au début de la
vingtaine et puis elle était vraiment
chouette j'aimais beaucoup un petit
problème c'est qu'à elle
j'ai parlé feront qu elle refusait de me
faire des fellations voyez moi j'étais
jeune j'étais plein de vigueur
j'ai essayé de négocier un bon nom elle
énonce ne faut pas que je faisais mais
l'importance du toucher et non c'est pas
fait pour ça non alors c'est moi
j'essaie mais elle essaie d'être
arrangeante puis elle me dit tu sais si
tu veux ça me dégoûte un peu monsieur ma
place je te fais une branlette
et moi je lui ai dit tu sais je me suis
mis en couple c'est pour faire des trucs
j'arrive pas à faire moi même
on à l'installation le ménage enfin ces
choses nous fait on s'est séparés et
puis après j'avais j'ai une nouvelle
copine quelques années non je ne suis
pas aussi évidemment qui était dans un
tout autre registre c'est l'axé ça
m'assassine histoire touche et qui m'a
fait penser à ça bah les différentes
formes d'amour s'était fait assez
débridé je dirais messages appelaient la
grosse cylindrée à peine je mettais un
coup de gaz elle démarrait pas y aller
comme ça et puis voyez le tempérament
j'ai un jour elle m'a dit 'c'est natale
quand on fait l'amour faut y aller un
peu trop timide pour y aller elle me dit
tu sais tu vas pas me démonter me dis
que c'est j'ai un petit fantasme
tu vois comme en cuisine j'aime l aigre
doux ah ben quand on fait l'amour temps
en temps j'aimerais bien que tu me colle
une gifle oui en matière de toucher le
digère mal tu me tues me foute une
claque
j'étais un peu pris de court comme ça je
dis tu sais chérie
moi quand on fait l'amour c'est un des
rares moments j'ai pas envie de t'en
colle et une jetée un peu embêté quoi
c'est pour finir j'ai essayé par exient
bref il me reste trois minutes je vais
boucler
en guise divin dernière copine on s'est
séparés quand elle m'a trompé mais c'est
pas très grave allait rentrer un soir
une soirée avec des collègues
moi je dorme est une heure du matin m'a
secoué dans l'île puis elle m'a dit il
faut que je te parle elle est hystérique
faut que je te parle moi j'ouvre a même
dit j'ai fait une grosse bêtise j'ai
fait une grosse bêtise et de métaphores
encore le plein de la banio lac du
diesel réinsère wallmart est trompeuse
et si ça pouvait attendre demain matin
aujourd'hui
j'aurais dû me douter qu'elle n'était
pas très satisfaite avec moi parce que a
été acheté des sex toys abus à internet
ces soirées fuck you were sait combien
ce rallye auto power je considère parmi
nous y en a qui connaissent si ce trail
c'est une dame qui présente des sex toys
et puis elle était allée puis elle
m'avait dit je vais avec les copines
j'avais filet de sang ben ali avait pas
assez mais enfin bref
et je me suis tiré une balle dans le
pied ce jour là parce qu'elle est
revenue avec un vibromasseur angel a
acheté le wonder box électrique
révolutionnaire en cause par le roman
nazaire on entend des spasmes mais elle
est revenue avec un vibromasseur en
marchant qui marche et ap ils
l'utilisaient tout le temps ça
m'énervait défaut je voulais arriver à
télé télé comme on ne marchait plus à
l'est plus
on l'utilisé et puis ça vous je l'avais
jamais vu vider le lave-vaisselle ce
truc
j'étais un peu jaloux comme esthétique
franchement il faisait des mouvements
une chenille sur une salade mettrait en
scène ils pouvaient vibrer bleus hier
plusieurs vitesses plus
moi j'aurais aimé ça je me faisais je
peux pas faire ça m'habite
je pars battu d'avancement je peux pas
envie de riposte j'étais allé au
sex-shop je m'étais acheté une vague
ginette ces boîtiers six mutations vagin
c'est branché sur secteur
au début j'étais méfiant je voyais très
branché sur 220 ch ou pas ma [ __ ] là
dedans c'était quand je suis d'abord
allé avec une carotte voir comment elles
sortaient s'il ya des épluchures
bon voilà on reste moins d'une minute
c'était ma contribution à l'amour
je vous remercie de votre accueil votre
écoute et puis place à la suite comme si
on se voit au bar tout à leur merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]